my name is jeremy foley our projects is
mom
Chris taito right now mega
Oh
would you work with your best friend
until you anything the way I look at it
is we all get together and have fun with
it because there's going to be a time in
our lives where studios are going to
tell us what to do so we get to get
together and do what we want and it's
great we have a lot of fun doing it I
mean just us hanging out we should have
a camera offices because we're quickly
doesn't exactly one day we put a camera
I mean we can
so anyway the web series called mobster
it's on Funny or Die the episode up for
the award is brian austin he plays
himself and he's going out for a play
about so to really get the roll down he
hangs out with the mobsters real loves
ya weirdo
method actor goes on a ride-along
actually we got a
I know I'm so far
next episode of Alan coburg you play
Scrabble Ziegler
your entire day I think it's me know
what it's for an actor I think the
biggest obstacle
that's the biggest ops
yeah charming lets it go
you know
I work a nine-to-five job
he sounds thinking oh this is the reason
roll through he not hustler that's all
they work at some time
no staff
yes
thank you thank you